this morning it is my pleasure to have
Professor William Mitch I call him bill
who is a very devoted and accomplished
environmental engineering he will be
talking to us to lit today about what is
in our water now a couple of things
about Bill I have lunch with Bill quite
a bit he's very committed to the
environment you should ask him about it
his house is nearly off the grid meaning
that he heats his water through solar
panels he uses a wood pellet stove for
heating his house and he doesn't have
any grass in front of his house because
grass is bad for the environment and
fertilizer so he's fairly serious so get
ready to learn a lot about the
environment okay let's welcome our
speaker well thank you Anissa and Aaron
for organizing this and thanks to all
you for showing up on a Saturday morning
a lot of people and just in case you're
curious a lot of people get worried
about solar thermal systems in
Connecticut because we are so far north
but it does work you might not get a
hundred percent of your energy in the
winter but you still save a lot of money
on electrical or however else you're
heating your your hot water systems and
during the summer you get so much energy
you actually have to dump feet but
that's not what we're here to talk about
today they were talking about what's in
your water and this is hopefully of
interest to you because after all you're
seventy percent water and you are what
you drink so it's important to know
what's in your water so we're going to
talk about a couple of things here first
of all why we bother to treat water and
since most of you may not be familiar
with how we treat water we'll talk about
the details of both drinking water and
wastewater treatment not to detail
because after all we only have an hour
but the basic points and then we'll talk
about some of the emerging issues that
are important to both Connecticut in the
world and talk about of course bottled
water because that's always an issue and
finally talk about some of the issues in
the developing world and what's going on
here at Yale so first of all why do we
treat water well the obvious question
for treating water is we don't want to
get sick and so the question is is what
makes us sick and some of these things
you're not familiar with anymore because
luckily we treat water and you don't
tend to get sick from some of these
organisms anymore but they are still
automatic in many parts of the world so
there are four basic categories of
pathogens the first one is helmets also
known as worms and examples of these
include hookworm and asterisks which is
also commonly known as round worm here's
a blown-up version of a hookworm and
these are ascaris worms coming out of a
pig intestine so maybe sorry about that
if you're still eating your doughnut but
what you actually swallow would be a
worm egg which is much smaller than then
these which can get up to about three
feet long there are about 60 microns
which to put it in perspective a sand
grain is about a millimeter about 20
times bigger than this but goes into
your body and grows into a full size
worm about an order of magnitude smaller
or amoeba and some of you have heard of
this Cryptosporidium another example is
Giardia Cryptosporidium there was an
outbreak in Milwaukee in the early 90s
and they the eggs the OSIS as they call
them tend to hang out in cal pies here's
a blown-up version sort of an artist's
rendition of a no assists in an
intestine emerging from the organism
emerging from the egg the most common
pathogenic organism tends to be bacteria
even smaller than amoeba and these are
responsible for such diseases as typhoid
and cholera and they can come in a
variety of shapes but here are some
pictures of some and lastly viruses
about 20 or 50 times smaller than
bacteria and they're responsible for
diseases such as polio which we used to
have a lot of outbreaks up until about
the 1950s in the US and norwalk virus
which is still with us and is the
sickness that's responsible on cruise
ships when you hear about the princess
cruise lines and these sort of
sicknesses that break out that tends to
be Norwalk or calicivirus and the reason
why pathogens are a problem they might
not have been a problem in
hunter-gatherer times for example the
real issue is population density when we
start crowding people together it's
difficult to escape our own waste
example that here is a village right
outside Angkor Wat in Cambodia this is
the town drinking water well
and here's sort of a cesspool around the
well so all this material penetrates
down into the drinking water supply and
so again we're in exponential growth
phase in population so worldwide public
health becomes a very important issue so
again here's that same picture of
Cambodia but this used to be the picture
in places like New York and London back
in the 1800s so up here is a picture of
five points which starred in that movie
gangs in New York but right over here is
the drinking water well these are dirt
streets and it looks pretty clean here
but the reality is it was probably
looked more like this in London back in
the 1800s houses were designed here's
the floor of a house here's the road
people would generally just throw their
sewage out in the road or throw it under
the house in the crawl space and the
reason why they do that is because the
waste product was known as night soil
and it served as a good fertilizer so
you send one of the kids down there to
muck out the cesspool every once in a
while but the problem was is you have
both hydrogen sulfide and methane and
the guys going down there with a candle
so you'd have these explosions
occasionally you might lose a kid so it
should come as no surprise that
epidemics used to sweep through these
new york and london and other major
cities in about every 15 years say for
new york in the 1800's nobody knew what
bacteria were back then they just called
them my as most they often thought it
was associated with the rotting trash
piles out in the street but they did
have they didn't necessarily know what
they were dealing with but they knew
enough to throw lime on walls so if
you're down the basement apartment of a
building this material seeps through the
walls they'd apply lime which raises the
pH up to 12 and starts to kill off some
of these bacteria they didn't
necessarily understand why but it worked
but one of the sort of major events was
something that happened in London called
the great stink in 1858 so again people
were throwing their waste out on the
streets or had rudimentary sewers to
dump it in the Thames and guess what's
right on the Thames but Parliament so
people were doing this and eventually
the entire Thames backed up and started
to rot so you had this incident called
the great stink and most of the
inhabitants fled but Parliament
stock in session and of course they were
smelling this through the windows so
they authorized the construction of a
major sewer and it should point out that
sewer comes from old english for seaward
you're not actually treating the waste
you're just conveying it out to the
ocean so you can get rid of it so they
built a major conduit to get rid of the
sewage which was the foundation for the
Bakerloo tube line if you go to London
and why was that because Queen Victoria
was queen back then this was a major
engineering project and she wanted to go
check it out but of course she can't
walk through it didn't have sewage yet
but a dirty tunnel so they built a
little railroad car for her so she could
go check out the sewer line so what are
some of the major treatment processes
well one of the first ones is fairly
simple it's been known since
Mesopotamian times first civilization
back in 3000 BC there are documents
saying well to avoid being sick get your
pot of water and let it sit for several
days so you can settle out particles
pathogens tend to stick to particle sand
grains and other things and some of them
can be large enough to settle out
themselves and basically it's just a
giant box you push your water or
wastewater through the box and particles
settle out and there are little scrapers
that move it into a trough and convey it
away so since this is science Saturday
would throw in one or two equations but
what we're again interested is particle
settling and it turns out I'm not going
to derive this here but particle
settling tends to be proportional to the
particle diameter squared so it's highly
dependent on the size of your organism
and again remember that worms are about
60 microns an amoeba about 5 microns and
from this you can calculate certain
settling velocities so engineering is
about designing things that works I
thought I'd just give you an example for
how you might design something in New
Haven using algebra so again algebra is
useful and what we want to do here is
will have that box that's settling box
here and you flow your drinking water or
wastewater through the box and it's
going to spend a certain amount of time
there but for a hundred percent removal
of a pathogen by settling it's going to
slowly sink as it goes through the box a
pathogen at the top is going to need to
sink a distance D within the time frame
it
travels through the box so we need to
know the residence time of the material
in the box which is the volume dlw LW /
the flow rate so cubic meters / cubic
meters per second gives you time units
so that's a residence time so for a
hundred percent removal our velocity has
to equal the depth that has to sink /
the time it has to accomplish this
sinking so we can simplify and you get
the flow rate divided by the surface
area so LW so the the top surface of the
box becomes the important parameter so
we can solve for very surface areas for
New Haven to remove different types of
pathogens so we know this settling
velocity we plug it into this equation
and we know the flow rate there's new
haven treats about 15 million gallons a
day of either drinking water or
wastewater because what goes in goes out
and we can say well what's land area
would we need to remove different
pathogens just by settling for New Haven
and for worms you need about a half an
acre no problem readily done once you go
down to amoeba remember it's
proportional to particle diameter
squared it ramps up rapidly you're
talking about 86 acres that's a huge
amount of land to set aside just for one
treatment process so basically it's not
really going to work and when you get
down even smaller particles forget about
it it's not going to work at all so what
do you do then with those other smaller
organisms just as an aside you know one
of the reasons we don't have worm
contamination in the u.s. anymore if
this is the most rudimentary treatment
process in the early 1900s a lot of
people started putting this in and worms
were no longer a problem well another
thing you could do is say to remove
amoeba is filter the system and this
gets into current EPA mandates to try to
require towns to actually filter their
water most towns do but cities like New
York City don't in New York City has
issues right now they're fighting it out
with the EPA because remember
Cryptosporidium hangs out in cow pies
and their drinking water supplies up in
the Catskills and cow
are farmed up there so they're walking
around and depositing cow pies in the
drinking water supply but the drinking
water supplies and filtered and other
treatment processes don't really get rid
of Cryptosporidium so the EPA is trying
to force New York to put in filters but
it costs about a billion dollar so New
York's trying to basically buy out the
cows so this can get rid of things like
Cryptosporidium but viruses and bacteria
can migrate through what as a filter
look like it's basically a bed in which
you have sand you dump water on top and
it slowly seeps down is collected and
goes on to the next treatment process
and eventually the filter clogs up so
you run water backwards and you scrape
off all the pathogens and wash it out to
the sewer it's pretty simple system but
when you start talking about millions of
gallons a day you start talking about
some very expensive treatment processes
but the major treatment is disinfection
so chlorination so chlorine is
essentially just Clorox so you'll
necessarily realize it but a lot of you
are essentially drinking Clorox used to
distant but it's obviously much lower
concentration so please do not do this
at home but it can come in different
forms the traditional form is just
chlorine gas and just to show you a
little bit of chemistry chlorine gas or
two chlorine atoms they tend to share
their electrons but when it hits water
it tends to split so one of the
chlorines grabs both of the electrons in
the bond and ends up as chloride
traditional table salt completely
harmless the other one loses both of the
electrons and combines with water and
forms HOCl hypochlorous acid which is
basically the constituent in Clorox well
chlorine likes electrons and it's
fighting with oxygen here so it's
unhappy so it tends to be reactive and
goes and tries to find two electrons
elsewhere and this is one option is to
go after a pathogen so free chlorine
plus pathogen ends up being dead
pathogen plus totally harmless chloride
so options for places like New York City
are to either secure pristine water
supply so here's New York down here and
they have
watersheds up here the Croton watershed
and the Catskills and that works to a
certain extent but there are issues as I
mentioned with Cryptosporidium and
filtration chlorine doesn't do a good
job of getting rid of Cryptosporidium
but another option is to for for viruses
and bacterias to use chlorine and just
like to point out here I think it's an
important point these days as we start
talking about how to help the developing
world that one of the major public
health achievements came about not buy
medicine but by environmental
engineering so here's a graph of typhoid
cases in the u.s. you see fairly high
numbers but in the early 1900s
chlorination started happening drinking
water supplies and you see a dramatic
drop in typhoid cases as chlorination
permeated out to smaller and smaller
communities wasn't until the 1940s that
penicillin came in sort of a cure for
some of these antibiotics for pathogens
it's good it's good to have these of
course in case you get sick but it
doesn't do a whole lot of good to put
all your money in medicine if the very
next day you get cured you go out and
drink the same contaminated water supply
you just get sick again so just to put
together basic scheme for drinking water
treatment for surface waters rivers
lakes you send it into a box settle out
particles maybe run it through a filter
to get rid of Cryptosporidium hit it
with some chlorine and you have a little
chlorine taste coming out of your tap so
that make sure that you don't have
pathogens growing in the drinking water
distribution system as it goes out to
you if you happen to have groundwater
well the ground is actually filtering
the water supply in a sense it's just
basically glorified sand filter so all
you really need to do is add a little
chlorine and comes to you so another
reason we treat water dissolved organics
it's not just about pathogen so in
pristine water supplies we have
something called humic substances so if
you go out to a lake or a river you
might see the waters actually brown in
some cases and what what this comes from
is leaves that rot over months to years
into a highly very polymer called humic
substances highly degraded very
carbon-rich microorganisms tend to pick
out the nature
in and phosphorus that they need to grow
and because it's been picked over for so
long the remnants aren't very
bioavailable so bacteria can't really
eat it too well well the problem with
this material besides perhaps it's
unsightly is that when you add chlorine
it reacts with this material because it
doesn't know whether it's reacting with
a microorganism or inorganic it just
wants electrons and you can form various
byproducts and so one of the byproducts
that forms is chloroform and you might
see that it's called trihalomethanes if
you look at the drinking water report
that might come to your house once a
year and people try to add various
coagulants to group these molecules
together and settle them out in the
settling tank or during filtration the
reason why this is important these
byproducts is that they've been
associated with bladder cancer so
bladder cancer tends to be I think it's
the fourth or sixth most common cancer
in the u.s. 50,000 cases a year twelve
thousand deaths and there are
epidemiology studies linking the
consumption of chlorinated tap water and
even swimming in chlorinated pools with
bladder cancer it's not the same risk
level as smoking we're not talking one
out of three people ending up with
cancer but there are significant
associations with consumption aid of tap
water and bladder cancer and they're
thought to be associated with these
byproducts so there are efforts to limit
these some other issues or looking at
the other end of the scheme why do we
treat wastewater well again we don't
want to release pathogens or sediment
that can sort of silt up rivers so we
want to treat our wastewater so we don't
contaminate down stream drinking water
supplies and again we can use the same
techniques settling tanks to settle out
particles that we talked about before
but when we start talking about the
dissolved organics it tends to be
fundamentally different from these humic
substances it's fresh organic material
so here is the generic formula for life
some guy back in the 50s looked at what
the elemental formula for various algae
was and came up with this thing called
the redfield ratio but it pertains to us
some minor differences but they
you're carbon-rich ch.0 is basically
this ratio of 12 to one is about the
ratio of sugar and then you have traces
that you need of nutrients nitrogen and
phosphorus now the reason why sewage is
important is because when you dump it in
a in a river or some sort of ecosystem
it serves as a food supply it is
bioavailable it's fresh organic search
for a food supply for bacteria so
bacteria tend to be carbon limited and
when you dump a load of food in a system
you can have bacterial blooms so you
have this population explosion of
bacteria and bacteria can eat that food
consuming oxygen just like we do so when
we eat food we burn it with oxygen and
form carbon dioxide and water and the
reason why this is important is that if
you are looking as we go down a river
say here's the sewage discharge we have
a certain amount of dissolved oxygen in
our water but as we go down the river
bacterial blooms happen chewing up the
oxygen in the water supply and
eventually after they've chewed up all
the food as the water continues to
travel downstream you get some narration
again but it's oxygen is very difficult
to dissolve in water it takes very slow
process but in this region of the river
you might not have enough oxygen and you
end up with a bunch of fish gills so
this used to be fairly common sites you
still see this in certain areas of say
up near wallingford on the Quinnipiac
you'll have some dams and there's some
leaking raw sewage that comes into the
Quinnipiac up there and you start to get
some of these fish kill areas so if you
look around some of the small dams up
there you'll see a bunch of dead fish
lying around but we treat wastewater for
the most part now so it's less of a
problem than it used to be so what other
problems can sewage cause this relates
both to groundwater and also just to
natural systems like marshes as I said
oxygen enter systems with difficulty so
let's think about bacteria for a minute
bacteria have certain enzymes that allow
them to burn food like us using oxygen
but there are various other categories
of organisms that instead of using
oxygen can use things like nitrate iron
sulfate or even fermentative organisms
and the difference between these is
energy per unit of food that they get
out of this reaction so we like certain
aerobic bacteria tend to be the most
efficient we get the most energy per
unit of food up here nearly 3,000
kilojoules per mole the other guys tend
to be less efficient so life out there
is a competition there's a limited
supply of food and all these bacteria
could be out there together but the ones
that make the most energy per unit of
food that they happen to get have more
energy to reproduce so they expand at
the expense of these other organisms and
so where there's plenty of oxygen around
on the Earth's surface or where we
happen to live we tend to find aerobic
bacteria as soon as you consume all the
oxygen because it's difficult to get
into solution some of these other guys
can start thriving and so here's an
example of a house you might have a
septic tank with a leaching field this
is raw sewage partially treated it
starts to seep down into your
groundwater system and eventually can
come out to a well over here and be used
as a drinking water supply well you're
loading up the system with food so
you're going to start this competition
going an oxygen takes a long time to
diffuse down to that groundwater system
so first the aerobic organisms are going
to chew up all the oxygen and then is
that food starts passing through the
groundwater you're going to run out of
oxygen these other guys are going to
start forming so what effects might that
have need a our audience volunteer here
for a second we have a special and
olfactory specialist so just we're had
to have an adult do this because this is
a toxic gas hydrogen sulfide so just so
you know you don't sue me I'll do the
same thing I didn't die so what is that
smell like rotten eggs so that's what
hydrogen sulfide smells like so well
might have you come back in a second
because we're going to treat this water
so it looks relatively clear I already
loaded it with hydrogen sulfide so
that's that reaction right there h2s but
we also before that happens we can
reduce iron to iron too and
brought some of that here and we're
going to see what happens in a marsh for
example load a little bit of this in
here kept a cap because we didn't want
oxygen to leak in here get some i some
reduced iron dump it in here we'll shake
it up and mix it hopefully this will
work we have iron 2 and sulfide work
great for trouble dissolving
dissolve and should do this will add in
some more what's going to happen here is
we're going to precipitate iron sulphide
solids if this works you bring the right
sold
I'm going to drop the pH too low this so
you can smell it but we force the system
it will eventually happen to add a lot
of us stuff though
hopefully this will work that's right
before I got here and it worked like a
charm but I guess what I'm getting at
here is if you happen to go out to a
marsh say you're out digging for clams
or something like that if you look at
the surface of the mud it tends to be
aerobic because you have tides and waves
crashing and so there is plenty of
oxygen there but if you dig down you
have an immense amount of carbon loading
in sediments so as you dig down you'll
see that the sediment quickly turns dark
black sometimes it happens within a
millimeter so what's happening there is
if I can get this thing to work is your
precipitating iron sulfide which is a
highly of it which is colored black I
might have to add to the whole bottle to
this so i jacked the pH down because
what happens is hydrogen sulfide is an
acid h2s and if it's hs- you can't smell
it because charged substance has to stay
in water so I wanted you to be able to
smell it but I just threw in some
hydrochloric acid there to lower the pH
but that tends to drive the dissolution
of the mineral I was hoping I didn't
overdo it but apparently I I did
actually this has to work all right well
we had a little bass correct this but
I'll try one more if not it will show
you the at least they treatment
technique and what what happens there be
too small to see but there was a little
kernel of it at the top all right well
I'm not going to be able to to get this
but we will treat this water nonetheless
so we're going to take chlorine so we're
going to re oxidize it to the iron three
form and the sulfate form and then we'll
see if it still smells and we'll also
see another effect that happens
hopefully that work
what's happening turning orange and
let's make sure that your nose isn't
offended so well let me shake it up a
little bit so that comes to this point
here when you leave your house for a
long period of time sometimes you turn
on your faucet and it turns red what
you're seeing is rust iron 3 formation
and if you oxidize iron it turns red
which is the color of rust we've done
that here so better they treated our
water but it looks nasty but it's
completely harmless rust it does not
hurt you it's just unsightly right who
wants to drink red water hydrogen
sulfide on the other hand is not good
for you all right so we can force these
systems to generate hydrogen sulfide
reduced iron reduced irons more soluble
it gets pulled up and you're well and
comes out your tap and then when you
leave for several months oxygen slowly
seeps into your taps andrey oxidizes it
to rust which precipitates out as this
nasty red solid and the toilet and if
you really force the system you can get
fermentation of organisms where you can
produce things like methane or natural
gas Marsh gas ok let me what I do with
this so what else do we have so what's
the solution to this organic loading
well basically what we do is just
duplicate what nature does so remember
you force the system you start depleting
oxygen in rivers and you get these fish
gills so what we do is just take the
natural process and do it in a tank
outside the river speed it up get rid of
have the microorganisms chew up all the
oxygen and the dissolved organics and
then pass the the organic free water out
into a river so you have a giant box you
bubble in oxygen and you fill that box
with bacteria and then you settle the
bacteria out and recycle them back into
the process and then what goes out is
clean water that you Justin
fact so the overall scheme for
wastewater treatment is you have raw
sewage comes in you settle out particles
just like for drinking water treatment
you run it through this system up here
which is referred to as activated sludge
where your aerating the system and
allowing bacteria to chew up the food
the dissolved food you settle the
bacteria out and recycle it and then
chlorinate it and then dump it in d
chlorine it because you don't want to
kill any fish and send it out to rivers
so one other issue with that is all the
stuff is settling out you also get rid
of some of the dead bacteria what do you
do with all those solids tremendous
issue for wastewater treatment disposals
expensive and you pay by weight you have
to truck all this material off to say a
landfill perhaps and so it uses a
process called anaerobic digestion you
essentially want to reduce the amount of
biomass you have in the system by taking
advantage of the fact that anaerobic
organisms tend to be much less efficient
than aerobic organisms so per unit of
food they have much less energy coming
out of the system so they can't devote a
lot of energy to reproduction they just
use that energy to stay alive so you
slowly chew down the bulk of your your
mass and in the process you also
generate methane so you generate methane
if you go by North Haven towards home
depot you'll see as you're passing over
a bridge there on the right you might
see a sight similar to this a little
flare going off well that's a bio solids
from the North Haven wastewater
treatment plant generating methane and
you flare off the methane because you
don't want to have natural gas leaking
out of the system but these days with
energy being so expensive it makes sense
to capture that energy and use it to
power the plants the New Haven just got
a system to capture it a turbine and
generate about thirty-five percent of
the energy used in the plant just using
the methane that bubbles off after all
this digestion you end up with something
called cake chocolate cake tastes pretty
good but you can use this it contains
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium all
the elements you need for successful
fertilizer so this ends up being
essentially free fertilizer just like
nights
oil was back in the 1800's for farmers
and so here you have these machines
flinging biosolids out on agricultural
fields what are some of the emerging
issues in wastewater treatment well by
activated sludge we handled the carbon
loading and removed the limiting
nutrient for bacterial growth but algae
don't need carbon they make their own by
photosynthesis but they do need this is
the generic formula for life they are
limited by nitrogen and phosphorus so
nitrogen phosphorus exists in sewage
because it's fresh organic material and
it fuels algae blooms so you get these
algae blooms up on the surface here's a
picture of some of China currently this
showed up in the Olympics recently if
you remember they were trying to have an
aquatics competition in the lake that
look like this and they had to quickly
get rid of all the algae same thing
happens in Long Island Sound when you're
at the beach you see these large lettuce
leaf nasty-looking algae well that's
from all the nitrogen and phosphorus to
loadings into Long Island Sound the
surface is fine because your boat is
synthesizing so you're generating loads
of oxygen so it can actually be super
saturated in oxygen but these algae
eventually die sink to the bottom and
then the bacteria have now a food supply
so they chew up the oxygen and your
bottom waters go anaerobic leading to
fish gills so there's a major effort now
for Connecticut and New York to try to
introduce new treatment processes to
remove nitrogen phosphorus from waste
water so that you prevent this process
and hopefully cut down on those lettuce
leaf algae you see at the beach well the
other emerging issues is the emerging
global water shortage so most people now
think that that oil is the major issue
or fuel as the major environmental issue
these days and of course it is an
important issue but probably as or more
important an issue is water shortages
and here are some various pundits we
have a former VP of the World Bank
saying if the Wars of the 21st century
or fought over oil the Wars of the next
century will be fought over water so
we're running out of water and it's
occurring both in the industrialized
world where oil of course is a problem
but all
so in the developing world were a lot of
people don't even notice fuels through
shortages they're completely off the
grid we'll talk about some of that at
the end but an example here is
California so you've seen pictures of
Los Angeles it looks like lush palm
trees but in reality it was founded in a
desert and so to supply that major
metropolis they've been piping water
into the city from various parts of the
West subject of the movie Chinatown was
the Los Angeles Aqueduct where they pipe
the entire Owens River to LA they then
built the Colorado aqueduct where a
major fraction goes to LA and San Diego
but also Las Vegas and Arizona are now
fighting over this water supply and
until recently there were there were
years when no water actually reached the
Gulf of California didn't even reach
Mexico Mexico is supposed to get some by
treaty so they're sort of cutting back
on the amount that la can get and
Northern California rivers have been
piped down California Aqueduct in all
these cases the federal government is
cracking down on this process of
importing water to LA ecosystem issues
up in San Francisco the fact that water
doesn't even reach the Gulf of
California and treaty obligations with
Mexico plus Vegas and Arizona are also
growing and they're fighting for the
water so for all and the EPA is forcing
LA to at least leave some water in a
lake that they drained to build this
aqueduct for all these reasons la is
running out of water and this is this
issue's mimicked in other states Arizona
and Florida and so can you import more
water or should you start using what
little groundwater is natively present
in la by recycling waste water so what
concerns would you have about recycling
waste water well one of the big ones
that have appeared in the news recently
are what's all in wastewater all of our
consumer products pharmaceuticals
hormones things like antibiotics so anti
bacterial or antimicrobial hand soaps
for example have triclosan and other
sorts of antibiotics in there and some
of the concerns might be well if you're
dumping this out in ecosystems on a
continuous basis if it passes through
your wastewater treatment plant are you
developing resistant pathogens some
people would argue yes some people would
argue no it's not really known at this
point another issue is something called
endocrine system disrupter so in your
endocrine systems hormones at
ridiculously low concentrations set off
catalytic cascades when they reach a
receptor in a cell so tiny
concentrations can have huge effects and
part of the problem is is that some
molecules look or behave like the
hormones that we use and can set off
these sort of catalytic cascades so a
one of the current concerns are this is
the female reproductive hormone 17 beta
estradiol birth control pills all
they've essentially done is modified one
functional group on the molecule so that
your body can't deactivate it so hence
you can control birth the problem is is
that this tends to persist during
wastewater treatment and there are
unknown issues about what happens if it
ends up out in the ecosystem or ends
back up in a drinking water supply
there's a lot of public outrage over
this and this has shut down a lot of
wastewater recycling processes in
California and the desert Southwest but
at yet as yet there's no demonstrated
human health effects and to a certain
extent this might make sense if you're
eating milligrams of dosage of
pharmaceuticals what's the chance that
the nanograms per liter that end up
ending up back in drinking water
supplies with a micrograms per liter up
to a million times left thousand to a
million times less are going to have an
effect on you so it's as yet unknown so
what do people do for recycling waste
water as I said US population is
exploding in places like California the
desert Southwest Texas and Florida and
there just isn't enough water there to
support it so already there are lots of
wastewater recycling plants down there
the earliest example is the place called
water factory 21 in Orange County south
of LA and what they do or officially say
they they're doing is preventing
seawater intrusion so you're pumping out
groundwater to use as drinking water and
the problem is is that you're drawing
water towards the well and you're right
next to the ocean so you might start
drawing salt water into your wealth
and once it's there it tends to be
fairly dense it's hard to get it out
again so what they say is well we'll
we'll use it as drinking water recycle
the waste water and then pump it back
into right near the edge of the salt
water to try to push that salt water
wedge back towards the coast now is the
official talk and then people started to
catch on well actually this wastewater
is eventually going to come right back
out you're drinking water well so you're
indirectly reusing waste water so it
became a concern people are concerned
about for moans and pharmaceuticals and
so how might you treat this wastewater
well one way is a process called reverse
osmosis so naturally if you have a
membrane that only passes water and you
have a high salt solution on one side
your water is going to want to rush in
to dilute that system if you push down
on that you can force the system the
other way so if we have for example of
clean we have clean water on one side
and wastewater on the other side we're
going to want to draw the clean water
into the wastewater but if you push hard
enough you can clean up the wastewater
and only pass very clean water out the
other side so people use reverse osmosis
in these indirect potable reuse
operations to clean the water but it's
extremely energy intensive so it's not
done for typical wastewater treatment
and actually the water can be so clean
it that there's talk about adding back
in nutrients like calcium for bone
growth and that sort of things there's
essentially nothing in the water so
that's planned a indirect potable reuse
and but this is starting to bring up
concerns that people hadn't thought
about before for traditional wastewater
treatment at these molecules
pharmaceuticals and that sort of thing
are heading out into if they make it
through wastewater treatment we
generally dump that in rivers and these
are endocrine disruptors and organisms
are equally susceptible to these hormone
actions so for example salmon use
estrogen like hormones during spawning
the female will give off an
estrogen-like chemical and the male
salmon will follow that trace upstream
to figure out where the females dumping
its eggs so it knows to show up and
fertilize the egg but the problem is is
that
the pheromones that the salmon use is
active at 10 to the minus 12th molar and
in wastewater effluent you have birth
control pill type concentrations at two
orders of magnitude higher
concentrations so the concern is are the
fish basically hanging out in the
wastewater effluent rather than moving
up to where the salmon are another issue
is feminization of fish and amphibians
organisms that live in water will mail
or what are supposed to be male fish and
and frogs see a lot of these female
hormones and start to become feminized
but here is an example of atrazine which
is a pesticide in one of these endocrine
disrupting compounds and this is a frog
gonad and people have taken cross
sections through it and you see that
this frog has both testes the male
organism and ovaries in the same frog so
this is starting to bring about a new
way that we think about water and
wastewater treatment a new paradigm we
used to look at rivers and say well it's
not rotting anymore because we have
wastewater treatment so it's relatively
clean so we can use that as our source
water for a city and yes we generate
waste water but hopefully we dump it out
close to the ocean and the oceans a big
place it'll they'll handle it but we're
now starting to realize is that there
are towns upstream that are doing this
process and downstream you may be
bringing some of this material into your
city so Pittsburgh's upstream of
Cincinnati so Cincinnati is drinking
partially diluted Pittsburgh treated
wastewater what are some of the other
effects well I was going to briefly talk
about some of the stuff that we study
again we talked about pristine waters
and you have humic substances that you
chlorinate and make various chlorinated
by products and these sort of
disinfected waters have been associated
with bladder cancer when you're dealing
with fresh organic material you have a
lot more nitrogen and phosphorus in the
material and so you might form different
types of byproducts in fact you form
chemicals called nitro sameen's which
were the carcinogens identified in the
1970s in hot dogs and beer and they tend
to be a thousand times more carcinogenic
than chloroform and they're uniquely
associated with wastewater so for
example we can take one of these green
algae and festive
lakes and chlorinate it and we form
small amounts of these nitrosamine when
we take a wastewater effluent and do it
we form orders of magnitude more and so
this has become a major issue for
wastewater recycling plants because this
some of these molecules are very small
and pass through ro reverse osmosis
membranes there are known carcinogen so
there's no issues about well are the
pharmaceuticals or hormones really
disadvantageous for humans and to get
rid of them you use very high energy
intensive UV beams to try to blast the
molecule after its formed so to give you
a local spin on things what we did was
look at our Quinnipiac River watershed
and sampled the for wastewater treatment
plants along the river and southington
cheshire meriden Wallingford north haven
and we're down here we went along the
river and sampled the river and look for
the precursor material the organic
precursors of these molecules as they
accumulate down the river so southington
you essentially have none Christine
above there and then as you go down
you're slowly accumulating these
precursors from the wastewater outfall
we also looked at the percentage of the
river that was actually wastewater as
you proceed down the river so we're in a
relatively wet area in places like la
some of those rivers that show up on
chips you know those old TV shows us
where they always have motorcycle races
that's essentially a hundred percent
wastewater those are things like the San
Gabriel River but in in the East we tend
to think we have a lot of natural water
well up in this is the spring season
where you have high flows start with
about five percent waste water
downstream of southington but by the
time you get to Wallingford it's about
twenty percent wastewater during the
summer in August you have lower flows
helping dilute this and you can be up to
about forty percent wastewater by the
time you get to Wallingford treated
wastewater so again I mention that
chlorinated waters are associated with
bladder cancer both in tap water and in
pools I wanted to briefly show you some
stuff we've been doing in pools so why
are pools interesting so we're looking
at sewage loadings and pools are an
interesting case because you're swimming
essentially in your own waste right
you have a lot of sweat and yes people
do pee in the pool and you're
disinfecting it also with chlorine so we
looked at the concentrations of these
nitrosamine carcinogens in various types
of pool so we look at outdoor pools and
this these mention you can use UV to
destroy this chemical so you have
sunlight that can blast away this
chemical indoor pools where you don't
have this effect and hot tubs where
higher temperatures promote reactions
and so you start at somewhere around six
nanograms per liter for outdoor pools
you jump up to about thirty nanograms
per liter for indoor pools and extremely
high concentrations for hot tubs you
have to look at this axis for that to
give you an idea the drinking water
concentration regulations for these
nitrosamine are down in this level so
you know fairly high levels just for
some local flavor here we look at the
Yale practice pool which is an indoor
pool but they use a combination of UV
and chlorine to disinfect and you have
levels that are much lower sort of
comparable to an outdoor pool because
you have UV disinfection this is the
penguin tank at the mystic aquarium and
it's an outdoor pool so you one would
think it'd be over here but actually
you're up near 100 about an order of
magnitude higher and again the one
reason why penguins are essentially
swimming in their own waste right they
don't go to the bathroom and the
bathroom they go right in the pool so a
lot more precursors what about bottled
water so you might think with all this
talk why don't I just drink bottled
waters and that's safer and so here you
have CNN articles talking about aquafina
actually being required to spell out
that oftentimes these bottled waters are
simply tap water stuck in a bottle where
they D chlorinate it so you don't taste
any disinfectant so what's up with
bottled water as I said sort of read the
bottle carefully because about thirty
percent of the market is glorified tap
water examples aquafina another issues
who's regulating this who's really
looking out for the health of your water
the EPA regulates tap water and that's
sort of their specialty the FDA Food and
Drug Administration regulates bottled
water you can imagine that what they're
looking for are the health of drugs and
humans and bottled water sort of a
distraction so they don't spend a lot of
time looking at what's in bottled water
how about cost tap water is less than a
cent per gallon bottled water we're sum
this up to a gallon would be about five
dollars a gallon so extremely expensive
and lastly there was a recent news
article about this phenol a a
plasticizer these are all plastic
bottles that leaches out of these
plastic bottles and this phenol a is one
of these endocrine disrupting compounds
so if you think about it many of you may
have notice this you stick your bottle
of water in the car and it heats up and
you have that sort of plastic taste what
is that well stuff leaching out of the
plastic so is that better I would think
not the other issue is huge amount of
plastic waste generated year one and a
half million tons so tap water people
don't like the taste of tap water
because of the chlorine but if you want
to sort of stop that there's an easy way
squeeze a little lemon in there the
score of a-- casa diz vitamin c and it's
used in the lab to quench chlorine you
get rid of the chlorine taste and even
get a little bit of vitamin c extra so
developing where i'll just want to
finish with this and some of the things
we do here engineers without borders for
some of the undergrads talk a little bit
about that in the developing world all
these issues are a paramount importance
because people are literally living in
their own waste oftentimes people are
drinking partially diluted raw sewage is
what it comes down to and so there are
huge health issues one and a half
billion cases a major fraction of the
world has ascaris for example at any one
time and examples mexico city they have
this river called the grand canal which
is essentially mexico city's about 20
million people all their raw sewage gets
conveyed up in a artificial river to the
northern state where it's used by
farmers for irrigation who are of course
exposed to all these pathogens another
sort of graphical example this is
cambodia again and here we have a river
where do you think the bathroom is right
here it goes right down the river let's
follow it downstream and we have this
sort of matt of nasty trash and what's
right here a homemade sort of water
distribution system
made out of bamboo is very interesting
little water wheel you can bay the water
up and pull pours into a bamboo slot and
goes right into someone's house but what
are they drinking so this is very common
throughout the world we went down
recently to Honduras and they count of
about a thousand people totally off road
dirt roads no power and they they
already had a springbok to collect water
they used to in the old days drink out
of a contaminated stream but they'd
already had a springbok installed to
collect clean water the problem is is
hurricane mitch came through and
destroyed the system no relation but
flow dropped by about seventy percent so
we went down there to try to help them
out so you have a spraying up in the
hills it conveys water debt they already
had this distribution system to convey
it down to a concrete storage tank and
distribute it throughout various
villages and the types of things we do
is measure things like flow rates of
various contributors to the spring
oftentimes with local materials is just
a palm leaf to help convey the water in
and measure flow rates test the health
of the water are there bacteria in the
water measure pressures in taps located
around the town to see how if you have
major leaks you can tell because you'd
see a drop in pressure survey the system
to figure out everything there's no
power here so everything has to be done
by gravity flow so we use surveying to
actually tell us the relative elevations
of areas and where you can convey water
by gravity and what we found is that you
have a springbok here so material
leeches out from the hillside and it
fills up a concrete box and then is
conveyed down to the village but
hurricane mitch had eroded out the
bottom of this box and so water was
seeping around and filling up they had
an old dam here so you had sort of
surface water here and pigs were
wallowing in the surface water so sort
of contaminated water they weren't
drinking this water but still a major
source of the water that would have gone
through here ended up here so we wanted
to capture that in some way so our idea
here was basically leave their existing
drinking water system don't mess with it
because they rely on that on daily basis
but they were getting much less water
and having to ration and instead try to
capture this water out front what that
had leaked around and formed a surface
water
and so what we envisioned here is here
is this surface water we're going to
dump into the trench here slotted PVC
pipe to let it the water seek seep into
the pipe and then we're going to
submerge it with sand and plant plants
on it so that pigs don't have direct
access they're not saying hey this is my
drinking water supply i'm going to go
root around in this this a saturated
soil here we keep it the pigs away by
just putting a natural soil collect it
in a box and convey that down to the
village and so we put in the slotted
pipe here in that trench filled it with
sand and gravel and so you see we
finally tied into another pipe that went
down to the village and the villagers do
a lot of the work along with us and
system worked and the last thing I want
to show you something really cool I
thought that we saw we didn't
necessarily do this but another group
was down there looking at local
applications for anaerobic digestion so
remember we're talking about North Haven
and New Haven capturing methane gas
coming off of the biosolids well one of
the major problems in developing
countries is again also lack of fuel
because people use wood to cook food for
the most part and so they're deforesting
a lot of the area and then as population
grows or just trees don't grow fast
enough so people are looking for
alternative fuel systems and you have
cattle walking around with cow pies so
why not use that as fuel and it helps
clean up the town at the same time so
what you have here is it essentially a
hefty bag glorified hefty bag a little
hole sort of wrapped around it and this
is proceeding downhill and the woman in
this house would come out every day and
throw the cow pies in this hole add a
little water to wash it down but it's
it's isolated away from the air so it
starts to rot you start generating
methane and this was all a locally
rigged system you have the methane gets
collected it comes up this pipe here's
the same pipe comes over you regulate
the pressure with a coke bottle so the
little pipe sits down in water and so
that you need more pressure to have it
sort of you can control make sure you
don't blow up the system by having too
much methane because that's it will have
to overcome a certain amount of pressure
to come down through the bottom of the
water
but if you have too much pressure it
will start to bubble out and then it
conveys further into the system and it's
used to heat to cook her food clean
natural gas and with one cow she gets
about two hours worth of cooking time a
day and no hassle with you know starting
a fire collecting the wood just goes out
and throws a cow pie in here so that was
basically all I had so you haven't you
take any questions